for some breaking news to bring you now
the islamic state
knife man nicknamed jihadi john has been
identified by the washington post he's
been named
as muhammad emwazi from west london the
militant has appeared in videos before
beheading hostages including the british
aid volunteer alan
henning well mark white has more on this
for us tell us what you know mark
well we should say first of all that
this is the washington post
uh who have released this story this
morning
claiming that this man who has been
branded in the
popular press as jihadi john is this
individual muhammad
emwazi not independently verified and
certainly
the police and other uh authorities are
not
reporting uh or not confirming this and
in fact uh are urging that uh we are
very careful
with regard to speculation because uh as
they say
uh lives are potentially at risk here
but
the washington post anyway has just uh
posted
on its website uh details of an
exclusive story that they have been
working on
uh speaking to people that they say uh
are
close friends of mohammed emwazi he's a
27 year old british national
who was born in kuwait and has lived in
west london w10
and the ladbroke grove area of west
london now according to the post he
traveled out
to syria in 2012 and joined up
with the group islamic state at that
time
and the washington post has interviewed
someone who's described
as a close friend who said that as far
as they were concerned
they are absolutely sure that it is him
they've also spoken to
those representing human rights groups
that have some knowledge
in this area as well who are saying uh
that they feel fairly certain
uh that it is the same person as say
scotland
are being uh very cautious and or urging
us
to be very cautious about speculating uh
but these are reports coming through
from the washington post this morning of
course
a very reputable news organization
who have been investigating and digging
down into this story and they are naming
this man who has become known as jihadi
john
as muhammad m wazi a 27 year old british
national
born in kuwait who left the uk in 2012
to travel out to syria and who joined up
with the islamic state and of course
uh he's known uh to us for these
uh horrific videos that have been posted
at uh regular intervals
uh showing the brutal murder of
western nationals including of course
americans
and british nationals